ahora que ya tenemos nuestra
parametrización justo aquí que definimos
como el vector r de posición vamos a
atender el asunto de calcular la
integral de superficies y es un poco
complicado pero lo intentaremos y lo
haremos paso a paso lo primero que
haremos es entender quién es este señor
de sigma en términos de aceite que son
nuestros parámetros así transformaremos
esta integral en una integral doble en
la región de los parámetros st y
recordemos que de sigma es esencialmente
una pequeña porción de área de nuestra
superficie esto sería de sigma y que es
una pequeña porción una infinita
infinitesimalmente pequeña porción de
área y que lo podemos calcular de la
siguiente forma de sigma de sigma es la
magnitud o la norma
del producto cruz de dos vectores y a mí
me gusta ponerlo con dos barras para que
para que no confundamos con el valor
absoluto hay gente que solo pone una
barrita para denotar la norma hablar
magnitud pero
podría prestarse a confusión quiénes son
los dos vectores que hay que tomar para
hacer el producto cruz pues será la
derivada de r respecto de ese y la
derivada de r respecto de t entonces ya
con esto dicho vamos a calcular este
producto cruz pero pues primero antes de
calcular el producto cruz pues
necesitamos saber quiénes son esos
vectores y la derivada parcial de r
respecto de ese simplemente será derivar
cada una de estas entradas respecto de
ese y si nos fijamos en la primera
coseno de t es una constante no depende
de ese y si derivamos coseno de s nos
queda menos seno de s así que nos queda
al final menos coseno de t por el seno
de ese seno de s que multiplican nuestro
vector unitario y ahora vamos con la
segunda la derivada de coseno dt
respecto de s pues no aplica verdad esto
sólo depende de t sólo hay que derivar
seno de ese que es coseno de s
entonces sumamos coseno de t por el
coseno ds que multiplica a nuestro
vector unitario j y ahora fijan fíjense
que en el último paso no tenemos nada
que dependa de s por lo tanto al derivar
respecto de s esto nos dará 0 voy a
ponerlo así 0 que multiplica nuestro
vector k
ahora vámonos con la derivada de r
respecto de t la derivada de r respecto
de t pues vamos a derivar ahora cada una
de las coordenadas respecto de t y la
derivada de la primera pues coseno de s
no depende de t por lo tanto es una
constante y sólo nos queda derivar
coseno de t que es menos seno de t por
el coseno ds por el coseno ds ok y esto
que multiplica nuestro vector y más la
derivada de coseno bueno estamos
derivando al respecto a este entonces la
derivada de coseno es otra vez menos
seno de t que multiplica seno de ese que
s es constante verdad
y esto por el vector unitario
creía haber cambiado de color por el
vector unitario j y finalmente hay que
sumarle la derivada de seno dt respecto
de t que es coseno de t que multiplica a
nuestro vector unitario acá muy bien
entonces ya con esto dicho ya podemos ir
calculando el producto cruz de estos dos
señores que va a ser un poquito largo y
de hecho déjenme hacer un poquito más
despacio entonces quién va a ser rs
cruz rt bueno a mí la forma en que me
gusta recordarlo es como un determinante
de una matriz ok déjenme ponerlo más o
menos
un poco más derechito
ok es el determinante de una matriz en
donde la primera fila tiene a los
vectores canónicos por supuesto esto es
sólo es notación no se puede calcular un
determinante con vectores pero bueno es
una forma fácil de acordarnos en la
segunda fila van a estar las coordenadas
drs
déjenme ponerlas va a ser menos coseno
dt por el seno de s
de ese en la segunda va a estar coseno
dt coseno de s
y finalmente como aquí tuvimos un 0 y
esto es lo que nos va a ser mucho más
fácil de calcular este determinante que
tuvimos un 0 al final luego en el último
renglón el perdón en la última fila
vamos a tener las coordenadas de la
derivada de r respecto de t que va a ser
menos seno de t por el coseno de s
coseno de s
- seno de t
por el seno de ese y en la última
coordenada vamos a tener coseno de t
coseno dt muy bien entonces ya una vez
que tenemos esto pues vamos a proceder a
calcularlo están de acuerdo
vamos a hacerlo entonces vamos a
tomarnos primero el el primer elemento
de este esta de esta matriz y vamos a
tomar y que multiplica si quitamos la
columna y la fila correspondiente ahí
nos queda esta pequeña su matriz
calculamos su determinante y esto será
coseno este coseno de sepor coseno de t
nos damos cuenta que podemos dejar
simplemente como coseno cuadrado de t
por el coseno de s y hay que restarle
digamos cuando multiplicamos estos dos
pero como aquí hay un cero ya no hay
nada que agregar ni restar entonces así
se queda nuestra parte del vector y
ahora nos tomamos el vector jota que hay
que cambiarle de signo verdad con
nuestro patrón que parece como de
ajedrez cuando calculamos estos
determinantes
se va a multiplicar a quién quitamos su
fila y su columna y nos queda una matriz
definida por estos dos y estos dos
entonces calculamos su determinante y
nos queda menos coseno hete por ccoo cgt
por seno de s nos queda menos coseno
cuadrado de t por el seno de ese seno de
ese que esencialmente si lo vemos este
menos con este menos se cancelan y
simplemente lo dejamos como un más y
esto es sólo la parte correspondiente a
correspondiente a jota vámonos ahora con
la parte correspondiente acá acá
entonces quitamos su columna y su fila y
si nos damos cuenta aquí ya no está el 0
entonces ya puede ser un poquito más
complicado pero bueno no puede ser tan
complicado vamos a hacerlo aquí
multiplicamos menos coseno etc no de ese
por menos seno de ts no de ese entonces
los menos se cancelan y nos queda coseno
de t seno de t por seno cuadrado de ese
seno cuadrado de s y hay que restar el
producto de estos dos pero como aquí
tenemos un menos se cancelan digamos los
signos y nos queda más coseno de t seno
de t por coseno cuadrado de s
muy bien entonces vamos a esto ya queda
bastante complicado se ve muy
espeluznante pero no lo es tanto fíjense
en lo siguiente esto de aquí lo podemos
simplificar porque lo morado lo podemos
factorizar verdad entonces tendríamos
que esto de aquí es coseno de t seno de
t que multiplica a quien multiplica al
seno cuadrado de s más el coseno
cuadrado de s y esto es muy grato porque
por la definición del círculo unitario
esto es igual a 1 entonces la parte en
que simplemente se queda con esto con
este producto que es coseno este seno de
t entonces vamos a escribirlo ya con
todo él con toda la formalidad vamos a
presentar a rs cruz
rt ante la sociedad y esto simplemente
es coseno cuadrado de t
coseno cuadrado de t por el coseno ds
por el coseno de s que multiplica
nuestro vector y esa es nuestra primera
parte más
coseno cuadrado de t por el seno de ese
por el seno de ese que multiplica al
vector jota y hay que sumarle la parte
enka que simplemente va a ser coseno dt
seno de t que multiplica a nuestro
vector unitario acá muy bien este ya es
rs cruz
rt ok esto al final es si retomamos aquí
de que es lo que queríamos hacer con de
sigma este es este producto cruz ahora
lo que nos falta es multiplicar por
cierto éste es sacar la norma y
multiplicar por las diferenciales de
cada uno de los nuevos parámetros hay
que tener cuidado con estas
diferenciales para que podamos llegar a
la integral doble ok entonces
vamos a calcular la norma o la magnitud
la norma o magnitud de rss cruz
rt ok y esto simplemente es la raíz
cuadrada esto es la raíz cuadrada
bastante amplio para que no haya
problema de cada una de estas entradas
al cuadrado verdad entonces vamos a
hacerlo primero con el primero el
primero con el primero entonces quién es
esto al cuadrado va a ser coseno a la
cuarta dt por el coseno cuadrado de ese
coseno cuadrado de ese y ahora hay que
sumar este al cuadrado que es el segundo
vamos a hacerlo y nos queda coseno a la
cuarta de t por el seno cuadrado de t
que si eres muy abusado ya notarás
algunos patrones que emergen aquí más
este último al cuadrado que es coseno
cuadrado de t seno cuadrado de t muy
bien entonces esta es la magnitud y se
ve bastante espeluznante pero vamos a
simplificarlo porque de aquí de estos
dos primeros podemos factorizar
de estos dos podemos factorizar el
coseno cuarto el coseno a la cuarta
dt y esto simplemente nos quedaría como
coseno a la cuarta de t por el coseno
cuadrado de s más el seno cuadrado de s
pero nuevamente por el círculo unitario
esto se hace simplemente 1 ok entonces
de esto ya sólo nos queda coseno a la
cuarta dt y este otro término entonces
realmente lo que podemos hacer es
factorizar un coseno cuadrado de t
entonces si factor izamos un coseno
cuadrado de t déjenme ponerlo con ese
color coseno cuadrado de t podemos
multiplicar por lo que nos quedó de
estos dos términos que sería coseno
cuadrado de t
se nos cuadrado de este verdad
y mejor aún porque esto nuevamente se
vuelve a ser uno entonces realmente lo
que nos queda es la raíz cuadrada de
esto último que es la raíz cuadrada de
coseno cuadrado de t esto va a ser igual
coseno dt bueno esencialmente debería yo
decir que es el valor absoluto pero
fijémonos que te que los valores de t se
están moviendo entre menos pi medios y
pi medios entonces si se mueve entre
menos pi medios y medios el coste no
siempre es positivo así que no hay
necesidad de ponerle este valor absoluto
y recuerden que el coseno entre menos pi
medios y medios está entre 0 y 1 y es
positivo entonces esta magnitud nos
queda simplemente como coseno de t de gm
entonces ya concluir quién es de sigma
de sigma era la magnitud
era esta magnitud del producto cruz que
resultó ser coseno dt pero hay que
multiplicarlo finalmente por la
diferencial de ese diferencial de t los
veo en la siguiente parte